so once a year I like to cross something
off my bucket list
last year it was write a book the year
before that was bungy jumping but four
or five years ago I was obsessed with
Banksy and I'd always wanted to do some
kind of like public art thing anyway so
I was like why not straight heart so I
bought a can of spray paint
I made this stencil that said love
recklessly and had hands holding up a
heart and I was all ready to go until I
found out it was illegal and I was like
oh man it's illegal I don't want to do
anything illegal so my solution was
to tag the sidewalk in front of my house
in hindsight this is this is probably
the stupidest thing you can do but I was
a teenager and I thought hey that might
be okay so I snuck out 11 o'clock i
spray-painted the sidewalk in front of
my house and when I took away the
stencil and I looked at my artwork on
this sidewalk so I ran around the block
and I sprayed the same stencil pretty
much everywhere on I ran home I never
did it again
now I'm not encouraging you to do
anything illegal but I hope that you
cross something off of your bucket list
this year just one thing I think one
thing year is totally doable and look if
it's on your bucket list it means you'll
be proud to have done it and you are the
only person who can cross it off so why
not 2014 hey happy new year live a
little you know and I did mention for
2014 I'm focusing on shorts
pre-production staking a lot longer than
I anticipated but hey that's what
learning is so I should have a short out
by the end of January or beginning of
February hopefully my minimum goal is
one per month so we'll see and I hope
you had a wonderful Happy New Year I
will see you on Monday for a little
special something I made and yeah have a
really great weekend